في شهر يوليو/تموز 1952 أطاحت الثورة في مصر بالملك فاروق على يد الضابط الطموح بالجيش المصري جمال عبد الناصر.
كان فاروق هو آخر ملك من السلالة العلوية التي أسسها ضابط طموح آخر بالجيش العثماني يدعى محمد علي عام 1805 بعد أن ارتقى سدة الحكم في مصر بفضل الحملة الفرنسية التي قادها ضابط شاب يدعى نابليون بونابرت
نزل جنود الجنرال بونابرت في مدينة الإسكندرية بعد وصول الأسطول الفرنسي إليها في يوليو/تموز عام 1798
وكان نابليون يهدف من حملته على مصر إلى قطع الطريق على بريطانيا ومنعها من الوصول إلى مستعمراتها في الهند
وفي أقل من شهر على استيلائه على الإسكندرية وصل نابليون إلى القاهرة وهزم أمراء المماليك الحكام الفعليين لهذه الولاية العثمانية
ومن أجل كسب قلوب المصريين قدم نابليون نفسه كصديق للمسلمين ومحررهم من طغيان المماليك
لكن المصريين لم يصدقوه وثاروا عليه مرتين
وعانى جيشه الأمرين في حملته على عكا وبلاد الشام ولا سيما بعد أن ضربه الطاعون
لكن بونابرت أيقن بعد عام من وصوله إلى القاهرة أن الحملة في طريقها إلى الإخفاق فشد الرحال سريعا عائدا لفرنسا التي مزقتها الاضطرابات السياسية
فاستغل محمد علي الضابط بالجيش العثماني الأوضاع وقفز على السلطة
ينظر التاريخ الآن إلى محمد علي بوصفه مؤسس مصر الحديثة
وفي عام 1830 قدم محمد علي إحدى المسلات الفرعونية هدية لفرنسا في إشارة لعمق الروابط وكذلك حسن التفاهم الذي يجمع بينهما